we've been doing a lot of rotating
around the x-axis so let's start
rotating around the y-axis and see
see what we can do or at least attempt
to
so let's say let me draw my axis that's
y-axis
that's my x-axis
and let's say let's just do it with an
example but uh you know we'll call it f
of x2 because it'll be generalizable
let's just draw i don't know y equals x
squared
looks something
like let me just draw the positive
because we're going to rotate it around
the y axis and it's symmetric anyway so
that's y equals x squared right this is
y axis this is x axis
actually no i'm going to state keep it
general then we'll actually solve it
particularly so we'll call this f of x
but clearly
this is y equals x squared this is f of
x
and we know how to
take the volume if i were to rotate this
around the x-axis but what if i wanted
to say
let's say the air the the
i guess we could call it the area
between zero and we'll just let's
actually just say between well let's see
i'm trying to determine how general to
be let's just say between zero and one i
think the boundaries might make sense to
you so this
roughly this area
and i'm going to rotate it around the y
axis now so i'm going to rotate it
around the y axis now so what's that
final figure going to look like it's
going to look something like a
let's see the base of it let me see how
well i can draw it it's going to look
like nope that's not what i wanted to do
the base is going to look something like
a cylinder like that
and then the top of it is also going to
be it's going to oh no that's not what i
wanted to do
let me draw the side lines
so then it's going to have a
it's going to look something like that
something like that
and then
i'll have the top of it
look something like that
and then but it's not just going to be a
cylinder right if i was doing this
entire block would be cylinder but the
inside of it is going to be kind of
hollowed out so let me see if i can
how effective i am at drawing that i'll
do it in a different color see
so the inside is going to be hollowed
out so it's going to
i don't know if that makes sense to you
that it's kind of like you could almost
view it as a on the inside it'll look
like a bowl on the outside it will look
like a like a like a cylinder or a can
hopefully that makes sense you take this
and you rotate this around and the curve
that specifies the inside of
would be y is equal to x squared but it
would be some it would be it would go
it'd be it would rotate all the way
around like if i would have drawn that
as well i think that makes sense the
drawing is the hardest part so how do we
do it
well even the shape might give you an
idea we can't use the disk method any
and what we were doing before when
rotating the x-axis that was the disk
method because we were essentially
imagining each of these particular disks
and then summing them up
now we're going to do something called
the shell method so what's the shell
method what we're going to do is we're
going to take instead of taking a bunch
of disks and figuring out their
combined volumes we're going to take a
bunch of shells so it's a shell so
imagine a rectangle right here
hope you can see it right there
let's say it's at the point
it's at the point x1
what's its height going to be its height
is going to be f of x1
f
that's its height
now imagine taking that
that sliver and rotating it around the
y-axis what's it going to look like well
it's going to look like a like a like a
shell it's going to look like a cylinder
just like the outside of a cylinder
let's see how well i can just cannot
it's going to look not too different
than that but i want to draw it well
because
the intuition is the most important
thing not getting the problem right
see let me see if i can draw this
respectably
and then
we're going to have the bottom of the
shell it will look something like that
let me finish these lines up
i think you get the point don't have to
be
okay so it's going to look like a shell
like that
and
let me see if i can
and so the the outside
the outside of the shell is going to be
solid
right
and it'll have some width
right but the inside is hollow right
let me do a different color
maybe a darker color to show that that's
the inside
it's a hollow um you know it's like a
ring essentially
and so what's the height of this ring
well i took this the height is going to
be f of x1
so let me do a brighter color so you
know what i'm saying so the height of
this ring is
f of x1 right f x evaluated that
arbitrary point we picked up
what is going to be
what is going to be the surface area of
this ring you know this outside
well think about it it it'll be the
circumference of this ring times its
height
so what's the circumference of this ring
well circumference let's go back to our
basic geometry circumference is equal to
two pi times the radius so if we know
the radius if we know the radius of it
we know the circumference well what's
the radius well the radius is how far we
went from the axis of rotation
to that point
so that's the radius
so in our particular example the radius
is x1 right the radius is equal to x1
it's that x point that we're evaluating
at
right so circumference is going to be
equal to 2 pi
times that point that we're evaluating
at and so then the circ the surface area
this magenta thing that i filled in
that's going to be equal to their
circumference times
this height which we already said is f
of x1
so we could say
let's call it area surface
surface area is equal to circumference
times height which is equal to 2 pi
x1
times
f of x1
right so we figured out the
the surface area of this now how do we
figure out the volume well the volume of
the shell
well what's the width of it how how
thick is this ring
how what's this thickness right here
it's you know it's a very small
thickness but we took this sliver and
the sliver as we learned in previous
calculus the width of this of this
little rectangle is dx
and you know we take the integral it's
going to get infinitely smaller and
smaller and we'll have infinitely more
and more of them so the width of this is
dx right let me draw it big
that's a horrible looking
so if this is the sliver
if that's the sliver its width is dx its
height is f of x one right
x one will be right in the center and
then its distance from the center is of
course x one
hopefully that makes sense so what's the
volume of this shell
so the volume of the shell this shell
not this one the volume of the shell is
going to be equal to the surface area of
the shell times how
wide that surface is and that width is
dx it's going to equal this times dx so
the volume of that shell is 2 pi
x 1
times f of
x 1
times dx
i think you see where i'm going with
this now
so what would be the volume
of of the entire rotated figure this
thing here well i'm just going to sum up
each of these shells right i have one
shell there and then here i'll have a
slightly less high shell and up here i
would have a much bigger shell and i'm
add them up right here's one shell
that goes around then there'll be
another shell here and i'll add them all
up and that's taking the integral
so the total volume of the figure when i
rotate it around the y axis
is going to be and my boundaries from 0
to 1
0 to 1.
2 pi
this one i just showed you a particular
x1 but we're going to sum them over all
of the x's it's going to be 2 pi x
f of x
dx right this is just a constant so you
could call it 2 pi times f x f of x
so let's take a particular example let's
let's do it for x squared let's say the
function is x squared
so in this case the volume is going to
equal let's take the 2 pi out 2 pi
integral 0 to 1
x times f of x f of x in our case is x
squared which i drew earlier
dx
equals 2 pi this is just x to the third
right x to the third so it's going to be
2 pi times the antiderivative of x to
the third well that's x to the fourth
over 4.
evaluated at 1 minus it evaluated 0.
well that equals i think i'll have
enough space 2 pi
times well 1 to the fourth is 1. so 1 4
and then 0 well minus 0. so it's 2 pi
times 1 4. and so that's pi over 2
pi over 2
that's the volume and we just rotate it
around the y axis
i will see you in the next video